[Music]
the Peter Principle argues that people
who have success and big hierarchical
organizations are promoted and promoted
and promoted until they reach their own
level of incompetence
after this they get never promoted again
and are often stuck there for life to
understand this better let's look at a
real-life example David and Diana two
graduates first met at a sales training
to become representatives for P Pharma
they were so proud to have gotten a job
in which they could actually help people
the company had just invented oxy devil
a promising new painkiller which the
company advertised as being non
addictive little did they know that they
had joined one of the most dangerous
organizations in modern America both do
a good job of convincing doctors to
prescribe oxy devil whenever one of
their patients has pain over the years
they all become friends and often
celebrate their achievements together
both deliver great sales numbers and
eventually get promoted to managers the
transition happens without much training
and while Diana was a great wrap she is
a terrible manager colleagues begin
disrespecting her and Diana
becomes very unhappy at work as a result
she decides to put less effort into the
job and doesn't realize that something
odd is going on some members of Diana's
team start selling oxy devil by the
millions to small unknown clinics david
is a natural he knows what to do with
his weakest reps and how to celebrate
those who perform well he becomes a
rising star in the organization and
after a few years gets promoted to the
position of Sales Director now when
Diana sees David in the cafeteria she
avoids him she's afraid to expose her in
abilities she is overly focused on
herself and doesn't realize how stressed
he looks David's new position as a
director is highly complex he lacks the
analytical skills to make sense of the
numbers he does not understand why the
sales of oxy devil have increased so
dramatically he feels insecure in order
to compensate for that feeling he starts
working extra
long hours the night before his first
board meeting he doesn't sleep at all
he's too afraid others will realize that
he's a complete failure at his job the
meeting starts with a science team they
present new research that reveals that
oxy devil is in fact very addictive and
that hundreds of thousands of people
could be affected the room gets
completely quiet then the lawyer speaks
up and confirms that there is nothing to
worry about as the product had been
approved by the FDA she adds that sales
should now soar until the patent expires
the marketing director is relieved he
can carry on running the same TV
commercials david wants to say something
but doesn't dare speak up there is only
one person who understands that some of
the people in the room have reached the
so called Peters plateau or their final
level of incompetence
this is Richard Succar CEO and member of
the billionaire P Pharma family so how
does Peter's principle work people
advance in their careers because they
have high skills in a specific task once
promoted these skills are often
irrelevant to the new job the new skills
required are above their ability level
or they may not have received the
required training note that their new
manager might also be a victim of the
Peter Principle and doesn't realize that
training would be a good idea and there
are incentives at play people often work
hard to reach a certain position or
salary once they achieve that some get
lazy once people lose their passion they
stop learning they may fail to keep up
with new developments which may
eventually lead to poor quality of work
in order to protect their comfort zone
they challenge any new idea or person
that can make their lives uncomfortable
employees that are incompetent are often
unhappy they left a job at which they
were fantastic and well respected by
their colleagues now they watch how
their colleagues get promoted or remain
equally stuck this has a negative impact
on the company frightened to lose their
jobs
incompetent managers celebrate obscurity
and implement complicated procedures the
procedures only make sense to the
manager and leave colleagues feeling
confused and uninformed some may work
very hard to make up for the lack of
skills for this reason their supervisors
don't dare let them go the results are
often complex and competent corporations
that move too slow to innovate the Peter
Principle was first introduced by
authors Lawrence Peter and Raymond hull
in 1969 since its introduction it has
been an often discussed topic in the
area of leadership in 2018 professors
Alan Benson Danielle Lee and Kelly Xu
analyzed sales workers performance and
promotion practices at over 200 American
businesses consistent with the principle
the researchers found that
high-performing sales reps were more
likely to be promoted up the corporate
ladder regardless of their managerial
potential which led to massive costs to
the businesses while our story of David
and Diana was fiction let's learn how
the real story unfolded
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects and simple language and
cartoons to support students all around
the world in their learning if you want
to support us you can go to WWII and
calm sprouts and donate just $1 from
many fans makes a big difference
you